I'm in bed at 11 45 I get a call from a
guy I had barbecued with last night
guy's name is kogan he calls me says hey
Pat how's everything I said great I'm
about to re-enlist for six more years
they got me everything I wanted he says
what do you mean I said I'm about to
stay in the Army for six more years he
says you can't do that I said what do
you mean I can't do that I'm doing that
I'm doing it tomorrow you can't do that
I said I'm doing it tomorrow I can't do
anything about I already told my dad I'm
re-enlisting tomorrow it's my ceremony
I'm getting an army accommodation medal
and I'm gone Pat you can't do it give me
one hour to convince you not to do it
I'm like you're not gonna do it one hour
on the phone
the things he told me
he shook me
I couldn't believe what he was telling
me by the time we were done I couldn't
sleep all night I woke up I couldn't
even sleep I got up in the morning I
went to Lieutenant Colonel peacocks
I said Colonel peacocks I got to tell
you something he says what's that
I said I can't re-enlist
he says what do you mean he said I gotta
go into civilian I got to go be a
civilian I think I can make it as a
civilian